hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast diversity of extracellular
vesicles and her cargo and saw the cell
communication i am dr. transports senior
application scientist at beckman coulter
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring because
educational webinar presented by
laboratories is sponsored by beckman
coulter agriculture is a leader in
segregation of flow cytometry has long
been an innovator in particle
characterization laboratory automation
in genomics agriculture products are
used to four pronged important areas
investigation and discovery more
information please visit beckman coulter
com removed important announcements
before we begin because what passes on
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the day you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
level presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge a slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or some
major problems is a green Q&A button on
the lower left I would not let the
introduce today's speaker got are gone
wobble lumpy on waffles professor at the
department of internal medicine at
University of Gothenburg since 2002
Collette research in 2007 assured I
systems to transfer functional RNA
molecules between cells having years of
the experience and translational long
research dr. Lola's current pictures
also introduces the biological function
of exosomes and other extracellular
vesicles and natural ability of
transferring RNA between cells dr. law
all was instrumental in starting the
International Society for extracellular
vesicles which can be pounded WWI seven
org he's the current president of the
organization
and which currently attracts greater
than 700 delegates to the annual meeting
it has more than twenty percent annual
growers I would now like to turn it over
to dr. lot all thank you very much Chad
for a nice introduction it's a great
pleasure to joining this webinar and
discuss extra celebes tickles their
diversity and their complexity in in
many different way so basically my
presentation will will be a discussion
around how diverse the vesicles are and
how and discuss a little bit how we
should approach this complicated
cell-to-cell communication pathway so I
come from the crafting Research Center
which is a research center in Gothenburg
Sweden we have about 10 people working
on necessarily vesicles and at about 15
people working in the field of asthma
which is my other field of research so
my declaration of interest is seen here
I have relevant for this presentation is
that I do have a few patents close to
being approved in the field so when you
think about accessible vehicles the
principles that that often are mention
is that they have a lipid bilayer and
the number of transmembrane proteins or
or receptors that that characterize them
so when you look at exosomes they are
around 40 to 100 nanometers but there
are many weak signals other vehicles
that are much larger than the the 100
nanometers so when you look at at
electron microscopy on the on the right
here you can see the standard electron
microscope a picture where the physical
seem to be cup-shaped but actually when
you when you look at cryo-electron
microscopy you can see that these are
are perfectly round vesicles and the
reason for this cup shape is
that they are deformed during the
processing for electron microscopy and
importantly you can find these extra
cell vehicles more or less everywhere we
have to remember that in biology and in
medicine these were were previously
called cell deborah's and and i'm trying
to ask my my fellows in the lab to not
use the term deborah's anymore of course
there may be may be broken cells but
much of the supernatant of cell culture
for example may actually be very
biologically important and may send
messages from one cell to another so
when we're basically discovered well
that's not so easy to determine actually
when you I guess the the XO song field
acknowledged these two papers very much
they were published in in July 1983 from
Rose Johnston showing that the
transferrin receptor can be released
from reticulocytes in in vitro and
actually more or less the same a week
later two weeks later Phil stall and his
colleagues published basically the same
thing in another journal so that was
really overlapping discovery a few years
later the term exosomes came into use in
this very small a scientific field at
the time however if you look back in
history there are other arguments to
suggest that there are functional d
sickles in the extracellular space and
guna rundquist from uppsala in sweden he
actually showed enzyme activity in in
the human prostatic fluid without cells
already back in the nineteen seventy
nine teen 77 and if you look even
further back there was discussion about
platelet dust which is probably extra
celibacy accessory vesicles release from
platelets back in the in the second half
of the of the 60s and if you go back
even further there were arguments that
some
infectious like agents probably Vista
calls were involved in mineralization of
teeth so the vesicle field has been
around for probably longer than we think
now if you look at modern scientific
literature and this is a presentation of
data that came out in journal of
exercise vehicles only in December so
you can see that there is a massive
growth of publications using either the
term exosomes or microvesicles or
exercise vehicles and that growth is
actually exponential actually if you
look at in PubMed with these search term
exosomes microvesicles or excess ella
vehicles or martyred microparticles
there are in total twelve thousand and
seven hundred forty six hits in pubmed
and more than half of those were
actually published in the last five
years only so clearly the field is
growing very very rapidly as Chad
mentioned we were we had a meeting back
in in in Paris back in nineteen 2011
discussing exosome biology with about
200 people and and we realized that this
field of excess early musicals and
exosomes the microvesicles really needed
a community a society so we started the
International Society for extracellular
vesicles now the name was not easy to to
decide on we there were a lot of debate
and actually voting by the community
before we actually decided on the name
but it was clearly an intrinsic need for
a scientific community and to meet to
discuss scientific problems so that
meeting was held in in in 2011 and after
that a year after that we were actually
in Gothenburg in Sweden here in in in my
city into in April 2012 with 500
delegates we went to Boston the year
after with around 700 650 delegates 700
delegates in Rotterdam and we expect a
probably a twenty to thirty percent
growth
a for Washington DC which is in April
this year we also started a journal the
journal for extracellular vesicles and
and that is publishing quite quite
extensively right now specifically work
in the field of exercise vehicles and I
should just mention that the unofficial
impact factor is we don't know what it
will be in the end when we get the
impact factor but when we do the
mathematics today is actually more than
10 so it's something a journal
definitely to consider if you're working
on excess led cycles so we're also
running the meeting as i mentioned in in
bethesda from the twenty-third to the 26
of april last thursday to sunday in
washington DC the bethesda north
marriott a half an hour subway trip from
Central Washington DC we have a number
of amazing plenary speakers we build the
scientific meeting around abstracts and
young scientist so that's the majority
of the meeting but we have a few very
good and interesting plenary speakers we
have GM Rothman noble our rate from 2013
on intracellular circle transport dr.
Phil Collins was actually the president
or the chairman of the of the NIH so he
will be they will be together in the
opening plenary session at I sep 2015 in
in Bethesda then we have exaggerated
brakefield who's a pioneer in the field
of exercise vehicle and Gary rough can
loosen RNA biologists from from Boston
importantly if you are working on
something and you want to come and you
haven't decided yet you can actually
submit a late-breaking abstract all the
way up until midnight central european
time I think it is in more on March 16th
that's about two weeks away from now so
come back to my presentation are
discussing the diversity of
extracellular vesicles so firstly the
work that comes from our lab I should
mention the not in the number of
different individual
including the the people that are
actually working right now in the lab
the bold on the on the left side here we
have collaboration with with edit poses
in in buda-pesht UC Irvine the tea gin
and quite an extensive collaboration
with South Korea Yun Seong go and his
team that have worked on Excel vehicles
actually much longer than even I have
done myself so when you look at exercise
vehicles it's really a conserved
function it's something that all types
of cells seem to be able to do so they
can be released by bacteria they can be
released by plants they can release by
fungi by yeast parasites so the really
present everywhere in our environment
and actually last year in in science
there was a very important and
interesting publication showing that
there are there's a high abundance of
bacterial exercise vehicles in the ocean
and an important part of the carbon in
the ocean is probably a harvested yo
present inside of excess cellular
vehicles so they're really present
absolutely everywhere and I often put
this slide in so many of you have had a
beer in the last week or a few and when
you did you probably had a few billion
vesicles that you consumed when you had
that beer so actually anything we eat or
or or most of the things we drink there
are XSL listicles so that's part of our
of our food stuff that we actually
consume
now if you look at the the current which
would call it current thinking or state
of the art today there are a number of
two principal be sickles that are
released by cells in a steady state in a
normal situation and those are either
exosomes that are released from
multivesicular endosome so they they are
budding of the multi secular endosomes
here and these endosomes fuse with the
the cell membrane and the release the
vesicles we know that many of these
physicals can be taken up by other cells
and and go inside of the cell and
probably inside of the cell the
mediating a lot of function but they can
also activates receptors on the on the
cell surface of the recipient cell now
microvesicles are considered to be
released by budding from the surface of
the cell and can also be taken up by
cells but are in this review from from
two years ago suggested to to primarily
fuse with the cell membrane where they
can release their target the cargo
inside of the recipient sell the
situation now is that we are discovering
a broader diversity of easy goals but
this is where we have sort of come from
and and we have to learn much more when
we actually dig into this complex
complicated situation with our current
research and work so actually when you
look at exosomes in a recipient cell you
can see that these physicals are taken
up inside the cell if you give a lot of
these physicals they can often be seen
throughout the cell but sometimes they
are seen primarily on one side over the
nucleus inside of the cell
so when we're looking at cell culture
experimentation the the vesicles that we
actually have in in that supernatant is
a mixture basical so currently we we
have acknowledged the present of
exosomes released from multivesicular
bodies we have acknowledged the the
release of microvesicles or what
hematologist oral coagulation people
call micro particles from from the
surface of the cell and then of course
we can also always see a little bit of
apoptosis in the cell cultures even
though you have may have a very very
nicely growing cell so that that you can
also see in your in your vehicle so you
can you can there are protocols
certification protocols that can sort of
enrich each one of these subpopulations
of easy calls into your isolate so when
you look at the EV producing sell these
vesicles can have different surface
molecules and actually even though they
are produced through one pathway for
example they the micro bicycle pathway
budding from the surface the each
vehicle is probably slightly different
from another vesicles having slightly
different surface markers and slightly
different cargo because when you do
large proteomic experiments or deep
sequencing for example or RNA sequencing
you can see that there are more proteins
and RNAs present in that isolate then
can be found that can actually fit into
a single vesicle so each physical is
probably a little bit of an individual
but the cloud of visa khals then can
have a a joint effect on the recipient
cell so these vesicles exosomes or
microvesicles can be taken up by
different pathways into the cell
and deliver their cargo in different
different ways inside of the cell so if
you if you start thinking about the
level of complexity in this in this feat
in this communication by exercise
vehicles in an organ or in a for example
a disease such as a tumor or tumor
microenvironment it becomes quite
complicated we have many different types
of cells in the tumor microenvironment
and all of these cells have the capacity
to release vehicles I'm not saying that
all of them release all kinds of
vehicles but they they can release and
they there are there is a mixture of
exercise vehicles inside of the of the
tumor that come from a mixture of these
of these cells so there's a extensive
crosstalk between cells in that type of
environment mediated by of course
soluble factors but also extracellular
vesicles so actually we've known that
excess la vista khals in the in tumors
can influence the tumor micro mayor of
my micro environment quite extensively
we've known that for for actually 13
years now this was a work published by
young song go from South Korea showing
that tumor extracellular vesicles can
increase angiogenesis in in in a kind of
dose-dependent manner in this in this
system so we know that tumor cell
exercise vehicles can have very
important biological functions locally
in the airways but also but also at
other at other size so actually it's
concluded in this in this publication
that they can promote angiogenesis they
can probably promote tumor invasion and
promote promote immune escape so there
are multiple functions that X
Sarah vehicles can do for example in a
tumor microenvironment which really can
promote or or attenuate I guess the the
growth of the over to me so when you
look at the nomenclature of exercise
vehicles you will be quickly confused
and and I think the nomenclature is
becoming slightly less complicated a lot
of people especially those not having
been around in the accessory bicycle
field for a long time still use the
terminology exosomes but you can see a
whole bunch of different types of names
here listed that's not a complete list
far from it but of course we are
mentioning the the three main types of
easels that we we understand today
apoptotic bodies exosomes and micro
bicycles so so the in the concept the
thinking is that the micro vehicles come
up from the surface the exomes are
actively secreted in from multiple
Sickler endosomes and april public
bodies are coming from cells that
undergo programmed cell death we just
course happens in our body on a regular
basis so there's actually and I will
come back to that there is a greater
diversity than this when you really dig
into the into the diversity vehicles
they're different morphology and so on
in this in this micro environment but
but I will come back to that later in my
presentation so there are a number of
different mechanism by which vesicles
excess led cycles can mediate in effect
two recipients l for the first one is is
surface a surface interaction and that
was published back in 96 x glossary
posing colleagues showing antigen
presentation but accessory vehicles to
generate 22 t lymphocytes that can also
happen with with bio active molecules
present on the surface of the XSL
vehicles for example Tina alpha
so here is the presentation from from
grass raposo back in 1996 which you can
see a clear activation of t-lymphocytes
delivered by excess led sickles watching
said at that time exosomes released by
by b cells and here she shows some a
electron micrograph of of a
multivesicular body that has fused with
the cell membrane and are sending out
the vesicles into the environment and
that's when she calls them exosomes so
when you book look back in number of
years perhaps a decade there were many
different functions that have been
described to accessories because I i
I've already mentioned t cell activation
I mentioned getting rid of the different
molecules that the cells don't need
anymore I also mentioned angiogenesis so
and there were a number of different
function that had been described and the
interesting thing was that these
vehicles could have for example a cell
growth stimulating effect in one system
and an apoptotic induce an effect in
another system and became quite a
confused saying what what these
different vesicles do and that may
depend on on the source of the vehicles
and and under which circumstances they
were acquired from that source when they
were tested but there were very little
molecular description of explaining
which which mechanisms which molecules
which cluster molecules actually are
important for these effects I should say
that there's still a lot of confusion in
that area there are number of papers out
there suggesting that one or two or
three molecules are important for a
certain effect but but when you start
thinking about the complex structure of
exercise vehicles you realize that the
the answer is seldom within one molecule
but actually a cluster of different
molecules that are delivered by the X
cela vehicles to indicate to any
recipient to recipient cell so as I
mentioned that we have surface to
surface interaction and we have the
shuttling of molecules including
proteins RNA and lipids between cells I
guess we are a little bit famous because
we were early to show the presence of
RNA especially in exosomes back in 2007
and we published that in nature cell
biology with the the two co-first author
Corrine Ekstrom and Hardy Velardi that
both spent a guess two years on that
project together so it was a big a big
effort to to show that and we we show
the presence of mrna as well as micro
RNA in the indie exosomes at that time
so what we what we did was actually
quite early to do some proteomics
experiment and we found some ribosomal
proteins present inside of the XSL a
mystical or or by the proteomics that we
had access to at the time which was of
the type of proteomics we have have
today so we quickly asked the question
is there are n a present in the exes
ohms it was quite quite quick question
and then are they actually protein
factories outside of the cell now we
haven't been able to show or to document
any protein production in excess Ella
vehicles outside of the cell but of
course you you start thinking that the
RNA is present in the exosome and at
that time we knew that exosomes could be
taken up by other cells you started
thinking can actually RNA be shuttled
between cells through exosomes and we
did the the analysis of RNA in the exes
ohms and within I guess two weeks we
know knew that the the RNA in exosomes
was there was clearly RNA in the excess
ohms but it was also different from the
RNA in the in the cell so we do not you
do not see the the ribosomal RNA peaks
in the in the our experiments when we
study
Psalms where as you can you can see that
in other other models but very different
from the actual cells importantly we did
not find a direct correlation of either
micro RNAs present in the exosomes or
mrnas present in the exosomes with the
with a cell so otherwise you should have
a line of identity here where they were
the cluster of transcripts will be
pressin this is using affymetrix arrays
so already then we we suggested that the
RNA in the exosomes actually somehow it
efficiently shuttle into the into the
vesicles and and and is different from
this vana it's not a random selection of
the RNA from a cell so the the killer
experiment I did we did a guess was this
one which we we took exosomes with mrna
from mouse cell line and gave it to a
human cell line and at this stage we
used a human mast cell line and a mouse
massillon so both of these cell types
were were the same of the same type and
we could see uptake of these physicals
and and we asked whether the mouse RNA
species would be entering the human
recipient cell and to determine whether
there was any translation of mouse
protein in the in the cells we did a 2d
page and and here you of course when you
add the extra somes here you see a
number of new dots many of those dots we
could document were actually Mouse
proteins coming from the exosomes we
done the proteomics on the exes ohms as
well but we found a number of proteins I
don't think this makes specific sense
but we can find a number of proteins
that the
the bioinformatics argued were coming
from from mouse and these were mousey
dc-6 sinking protein 271 and CX 782 just
as examples of mouse mrnas that seem to
be be translated in the recipient human
muscle so that argued that the at least
the mRNA was functional in recipient
cell and actually you can you can get
that RNA it's not damaged in the process
of transferring but it actually enters
the cell and does something in the
recipient cell so we didn't do
functional studies of micrornas but we
found a different lots of different
micro RNAs and one that is often seen a
top of the list if izmir 451 and and you
will see that in most exosome studies
looking at RNA presence in in excel
vehicles and a number of other ones that
were also present but this was early
days right this was an array performed
in 2006 so it was it was it was not as
detailed as the data you would get today
so other people however have have looked
at the functionality of micro RNAs from
from excel vehicles in this case using a
diff race activity assay so Michelle
Patel was early to present that that
functionality of the microRNAs in the
recipient cells how it's still not so
easy to understand whether the RNA in
the excess ohms as a as a bulk volume of
molecules that are introduced to
recipient cell are important for the
biological effect of the excess early
musicals we performed one experiment
that seemed to argue that maybe some of
the effects are actually and indeed
induced by the by the RNA
so this was work published in 2010 bye
bye Marie yelled and we published it in
in in in plus one actually so what we
did in this case to harvest exosomes
either from normal cell culture in this
case it's a mouse mast cell line and we
also used exosomes released from the
same cell line when the cells have been
exposed to a non toxic dose of oxidative
stress superoxide basically and we took
those exosomes and gave them to
recipient cells and then we expose these
cells to oxidative stress so the
question was do these exercise here or
here for that matter induce any
protective effect or mediate and a
protective effect two oxygen stress so
we firstly we looked at the MRNA
transcripts here you can see the
transcripts present in only in normal
exosomes but not in in exosomes from
oxidative stress but actually of course
it was were a number of mrna transcripts
that were present in in both of these
times but they were unique RNAs that
were were present in the vesicles after
that oxygen stress so we could see that
the the extra Soames actually change
their their cargo their content in that
situation so what we did then was quite
a simple experiment and what I was
looking at a viability curve if they
were exposed if the cells were given
oxygen stress exosomes they had a better
survival than if they were given control
exosomes and the oxidative stress was
given at time time point zero so that
argued that you could see a functional
effect on the of the excess
in circles these were coming from the
same cell they change their cargo and
you can see a change in biological
effect in the recipient in the recipient
cell and what we did then was to to
prove or disprove that the function was
mediated or possibly mediated by own a
was to expose the exosomes to UV light
and and I asked many many RNA
researchers at that time in the late two
thousand decade first decade of 2000 how
should you test this and and the uniform
answer I got was do exposed to these
girls to to UV light because they were
primarily damage the the RNA molecules
not only but primarily so this
experiment has some limitations but it
was an early one to suggest the press
the effect of of of RNA in the Indian
the vehicles so here you can see the the
Oxford the viability after UV light
after oxidative stress in in in cells
exposed to normal exosomes it cells
exposed to UV exposed exosomes or in in
cells that were given the same exosomes
as the as these cells but these had been
exposed to to UV light so the UV light
sort of eliminated that protective
effects which suggests that that the RNA
may be involved in that in that process
we were not first to show the presence
of nucleotides outside of the cells
actually there's a publication this is
Earth's earliest one I have seen
mentioned that was published in in in IA
1948 suggesting more than 60 years ago
suggesting almost 70 years ago
suggesting the the presence of nucleic
acid in in in plasma and the
presentation was done in 19 2 1947 we
also know that
a top totty bodies there is there's both
RNA and DNA and there seem to be
specific packaging of these molecules
inside of the AP operatic bodies and I
was published if not two thousand even
earlier than than that in 2006 Rutter
Chuck and colleagues presented also the
presence of mrna orb RNA in in micro
bicycles their RGB sickles and they show
that the the the vesicles could actually
have a effect in the to reprogram
hematopoietic progenitors and they
suggesting that either the protein or
the mRNA present in the microvesicles
was involved in that in that effect
there's also DNA DNA in xslt vesicles
maybe not in all exercise vehicles but
in some axela vehicles you can see that
so there was a publication only last
year suggesting that you can look for
for DNA to look at mutations of chaos
and p53 in excess Ella bicycles for
example in in cancer and there was also
publication even before that to show the
tumor microvesicles actually contain DNA
fragments and that's from you on Scoob
who was working with Sandra brakefield
at the time so we have pursued some work
to look at XS Ella vehicles in in
different body fluids so we were not
first but we we show the person above
the exosome o RNA in blood plasma we
were early also to show it in in saliva
I think we were first to show the
presence of external RNA in breast milk
by Cecilia Lester at the time and others
have shown the presence of excess LOL
RNA excess formal RNA also in urine so
basically whichever body fluid you look
into you can you can find the precedent
of exercise vehicles and other types of
molecules as well with with RNA so there
are
many vesicles basically everywhere so
especially I guess the the concept that
breast milk contain a lot of important
functional probably micro RNA molecules
and other Moloch RNA molecules suggest
that there may be a communication
between two individuals in this case the
mother and the child and actually
there's a paper that that came out i
think it was 2007 already there showing
that exosomes have immune model hood
features and actually induce t
regulatory cells that is work that also
came from from from sweden but from
karolinska institute in in stockholm
they didn't show the mechanism by which
this happen but it was very important
discovery at this at the time showing
immune modulatory function of of breast
milk exosomes and I think the lot of
investment is going into understanding
how breast milk exosomes can do
different things in in in in health so
all the vesicles important in in vivo
here is one experiment one study that
came out last year from from Stephan
mama who used a mouse model which has a
kree mrna and the reporter assay in the
same in the same house and he can see
here that when he actually induce a
peritonitis you can see the the reporter
function here in the in the brain of
these mice or you can in inject the the
exosome into the brain you can see
effects in the brain of the exosomes he
is hypothesizing hear that that exosomes
from the inflammation the acute
inflammation in this case are actually
transferred over the blood-brain barrier
and effect effect can affects the brain
so that's a I think a very important
discovery in publication that that may
have big implications to
understand communication between the
immune system and the brain and the
other way around so as I as I mentioned
when you look at in cell culture you
have a whole series of different
vehicles you have exosomes you have
micro bicycles and you have a pop topic
bodies and we have tried to look into
the different RNA cargo in these subsets
of ethical so what we do when we isolate
the the exes ohms microvesicles and an
epic tajuk blood bodies is actually a
sequential certification protocol before
I go into that though I'll mention this
study which actually is looking into
fetal bovine serum so fetal calf serum
is of course used a lot in in in cell
cultures and and a lot of people have
implemented one and a half hour exosome
depletion protocols to from from field
calf serum to get rid of that that
possible functional effect so gamma
shell key in our lab show the presence
of of exosomes in electron microscopy it
could also see that the fetal calf serum
exosomes in this case with staying with
PK HTC 7 can be taken up by recipient
cells quite efficiently and and also
there is there is a significant amount
of RNA present in the fetal calf serum
exosomes so an important importantly
here we looked at a a reverse
transmigration assay and you can see a
dose-dependent transmigration of all
these cells what when you put XSL at
vehicles from from fetal calf serum on
them so the field calcium exosomes are
clearly very biologically active now if
you if you deplete the the field calf
serum and compared with non depleted
field calf serum you can get a
significant reduction
of the of the transmigration but
actually you do not get a total
elimination of that trans migratory
effect so the fetal calf serum is still
having biological effects on other
recipient cells even though most of the
physicals are all removed probably
ninety five percent and when we look at
the the fetal calf serum RNA that's
without segregation or with one and a
half hour Santa fication or with 18
hours and education you can see that 18
our certification is required to
actually remove the field calf serum
rrna so so when you when you deplete
field calf serum from exosomes if you
using if you're using field calf serum
in your systems you should do an 18 hour
or overnight segregation protocol to
really know that most of that
biologically highly functional vesicles
are eliminated so we've also looked into
the presence of different types of RNAs
in in the in different types of ethical
specifically looking at epic rotting
bodies microvesicles in exosomes and
when we do that we use differential
certification protocols using using
different types of centrifuges in that
isolation method so you basically enrich
each population by doing that but but
actually it's not 100% clean of course
which you should should realize so
that's trying to look at if there are
differences between these different two
subsets of a circles in their cargo so
when we when we look at that here you
see the electron microscopy pictures of
extracellular circles these are exosomes
the smallest vesicles from three
different cell types some of the human
mast cell
line human ERISA leukemia cell line or a
mouse macro glial cell line and you can
see no ribosomal RNA peeks at all in in
these X's ohms and difference in the
presence of RNA in the vesicles from
these different cell types if you look
at the micro bicycles you again you see
slightly different structure here you
see slightly slightly bigger vehicles
and sometimes you do not see any RNA at
all in these two salons but in other
other cell lines here the arrow through
leukemia salon you do see ribosomal RNA
Peaks as well as a small RNA peak so
that's basically showing that the
vesicles do have different RNA cargo so
you enrich for these different RNA car
goes in the different isolates and this
is the April product bodies again you
see totally different structures which
are non cellular but but complicated and
and again you see RNA in all of these as
what's known more than more than 10
years ago 15 years ago but you see a lot
of ribosomal RNA which is very different
from what you see in exosomes where you
primarily see small RNA and no ribosomal
RNA so the different subsets of s equals
as we know them today do contain
different RNAs and and we have to
remember that many of the studies that
have been published or are about to be
published as well do contain mixture
vesicles we all you all if you're doing
research in this field and other we as
well do end up with a mixture of
different types of easy codes with
different sizes and densities and and
and and cargo having a collective effect
on an honor recipient cell so we have to
be very careful to describe the
protocols in great detail you have to
say which type of rotor you're using for
the identification you have to explain
where there's a swinging bucket rotor or
it's a fixed angle rotor when you're
doing this experiment so that's
extremely important
and information to put into the methods
or papers in this in this area so when
we when we look at the the unique or
micro RNAs in the different cells again
we can see here that that there are a
number of unique rnase in the in the
cells there are none in the
microvesicles there are very few in the
apoptotic bodies but in the exes ohms
there is a quite a large number that are
unique that confound in very low
concentration in the other example in
the other samples so as I mentioned I
cannot show this the details of this
data but one of the micro RNAs not
surprisingly is mere 14 51 that is
present in many different types of
accelerations so there's a vast
diversity of exercise vehicles they have
different RNA species and the different
subsets of a circles there is different
on a protein cargo in the different in
the different vehicles and and Cecelia
Lester has been working I think it's
three years now on describing two
subsets what seems to be two subsets of
exosomes with different protein cargo
different am on a cargo different micro
micro RNA cargo and even different life
lipidomics in two types of vehicles that
in at least in the literature are
considered to be excess owns so keep
your eyes open for that work it will be
quite important when published now you
can also look into EV diversity using
electron microscopy and as I mentioned
there's a lot of people that have
started look at cryo-electron microscopy
recently of exercise bicycles I have
been very fortunate to to employ Johanna
hug who is an expert in that field and I
will show some of her figures even
though they are they're not published
yet so you can you can really see the
detailed morphology of these exercise
vehicles when you use cryo-electron
microscopy the important thing here is
you need fresh materials you freeze it
snap free [ __ ] freeze it they remain
there their structure and then you can
you can look at them
look at them with the electron
microscopy undisturbed and here you can
see this is work from from a road at all
from from from France where they look at
plasma exercise vehicles they can see
the the double membrane here are the
vehicles they can see different sizes of
xslt vesicles they even quantify the
exits la vista calls in in some detail
so this is the percent vesicles
depending on their their size the you
can see majority here are between 100 to
1 nanometers and the average is around
275 nanometers in diameter with a
significant variability and actually you
can see some very very large and some
quite small exercise bicycles in this
using this approach you can you can even
see very complicated in circles you can
see here this one is actually connected
with this one and this is suggested to
come from a from a and even hear from
Quebec confirm a red blood cell so you
can actually find quite complicated
exercise vesicles in human plasma and
that's platelet poor as poor as my
should say this is from your honor and
colleagues published in Gion Alexis led
sequels in 2013 here again you can see
different types of exercise vehicles
sometimes with particles and round them
I don't know exactly what that is but
you can see there's some difference is
in electron density between the vehicles
as well again showing a quite vast
diversity here is another electron
micrograph from the you wanna study
published in Jeff where you can
sometimes for example see a vesicle
inside of a vesicle inside of a vehicle
so that's quite interesting and we don't
really understand how that actually
appears another one that it's highly
electron-dense that has particle around
them prolonged one etc etc so they're a
whole a whole number of different
vesicles present in human blood all the
time in healthy healthy blood so here
they also show the the vesicles from a
rupture plateless and they also release
can release a lot of insults into the
microenvironment i mentioned platelet
dust early in my presentation so there
are a whole bunch of different vehicles
that are released by by platos as well
during for example coagulation here are
some work from from from our laboratory
we can see a number of very small
structured a vehicle like structure that
we know are highly biological activities
are even down to below 40 nanometers and
in diameter sometimes these are from
cell cultures and here you see cry
electron micrograph with a lot of
different vehicles with different sizes
and different electron density so
there's there's really huge huge
diversity so the diversity when you look
at it from a morphological perspective
is actually very very diverse so what
I've shown you data on a little bit at
least is that clearly microvesicles and
and at least two subsets of exosomes and
apoptotic bodies or distinct subtypes of
excess and vesicles and within those
isolates that you actually get there are
probably a more complicated diversity as
as well and when we looked at at
morphology probably there at least seven
different subpopulations released from
one different type of cells so it
becomes a little bit complicated when
you're thinking from from that
perspective so basically to sum up my
presentation will you think about the
micro moment in an organ or in a tumor
or or in the bone marrow or anywhere
actually in the body we each each cell
type have the capacity to release
different types of vehicles multiple
types of easy calls from each cell
subsets and and these multiple subsets
of a circles can be taken up by the
different cells so there is a
communication going on among these cells
that is actually quite complicated and
these vehicles can contain they can
mediate surface to surface interaction
they can they can deliver RNA they can
deliver DNA they can deliver proteins
they can deliver lipids that may have
biological functions so there's a very
high level of complexity in this in this
communication system and one of the one
of the messages i want to to bring to
your attention during this presentation
is that when you when you're doing this
research you have to have a very clear
question understand what your question
is is your question what does the secret
or what is the complexity of ethical so
the multitude of easy goals that are
present in the in the in the
interstitium for example of a tumor is
that the U is your question what do they
do in recipient cell where is your
question what this subsets of Ezekiel is
doing or what this subset of Ezekiel is
doing and as long as you're clear what
your what your question is I think this
field can move forward quite quickly
because there's so much exciting
communication going on in this in this
complicated systems we should not forget
of course not forget that excess le
vehicles from for example tumors can
leak out into the circulation and there
are quite a few publications out there
now suggesting that you can use either
protein or RNA in the xslt vesicles as
biomarkers of disease as biomarkers of
disease progression so there's a huge
investment in that field right now and
keep your eyes open for that for that
research so in summary then I've shown
your door or discuss the diversity of x
ella vehicles XSL vehicles from one cell
type have different cargos and probably
different function
in a recipient cell EVs can be shuttle
between cells they can deliver their RNA
they can deliver their proteins that can
deliver lipids to the recipient cell
there's a vast diversity of vehicles in
the in the body there the vehicles in
the blood or probably primarily from
platelets and red blood cells but there
are other vehicles there as as well and
clearly there is an interest here in
using xslt vesicles also asked us
biomarkers so and if you're doing in
vitro experiments and if you using fetal
calf serum think about it very very
carefully because there are very highly
active by your active XSL avicii khals
there and they do contain RNA we know
that a lot of the sequences of RNA are
retained between between bovine and and
humans so that's something to remember
finally please come to Boston and enjoy
the the biggest and the most interesting
xslt vesicle meeting in the world world
community really opened to to good
collaborations and interactions so
that's the place to be when you want to
discuss exercise vehicles thank you very
much for your attention back to kill a
button presentation will try to answer
as many questions while we'll wait for
additional questions to come in and
we'll answer a few of the interesting
questions all right those so the first
question is is there any specific
recognition and uptake of secreted
exosome by targeted cells and target
cells possibly reject exosomes
so back to me I am now so that's
question number I don't know which
question you could type into the chat
box chat if you if you can but so the
question is do all cells I guess the
question is do all cells actually take
up the vesicles or do they not take up
the basically and I think that that
question is still a little bit open we
don't we don't know where they're all
says cells take up all basically clearly
some cells have a greater propensity of
taking up vesicles in general for
example macrophages if you look into the
lung whereas epithelials us yes they can
take up be sickle cell but the the the
most of the musicals are probably taken
up by by macrophages in that milieu so
reject the vesicles I I can't I can't
answer that question in a conclusive way
at this time please please say the the
number of question as well when you when
you bring it to me child please Oh Chad
our next question is on the protein
markers systems versus microvesicles vs
apple hot bodies or is it largely sighs
and or RNA content oh I ok I'm I'm back
now so if you look for example at cd63
cd9 and cd81 which were initially
considered to be specifically
specifically is present in in exosomes
they can also be fined in isolates or
microvesicles as well as in apoptotic
bodies so I don't think there's there's
yet a answer to tell the community how
many vesicles in in an isolate has cd63
for example in our in our hands it seems
to be a minority of the vehicles that
have see
63 all even though it has been shown to
be be a marker of exosomes so so I you
have to do very intricate experiments
actually to to find a biomarkers that is
very specific for subsets of of exercise
of ease because I don't think I don't
think we have one yet back to Chad the
answer to that question is probably no
unless there is a specific surface
marker or for example a tumor cell that
is present on the exercise but you don't
know for sure whether the tumor exosome
actually Harbor that surface molecules
so I I cannot think of a technique that
really with one hundred percent
certainty say that one basical firstly
we cannot do proteomics or protein
analysis of single musicals yet so
that's that's not there except maybe in
some specialized lab where they can look
at at facs analysis of subsets of a
circles of individual basically that's
down to the 5 50 nanometer size are not
smaller so so the answer to that
question is maybe we don't know yet I
guess that's my answer
thank you next question is how much
sample is required to isolate exercise
for a lot less effect or downstream
analysis and we know that okay I'm back
now I am in control thank you so that's
a very important question and we use
quite large cell culture volumes around
600 milliliters Oh point six liters of
cell culture to fill the the the
ultra-sensitive huge when we are
isolating the the XSL the vesicles of
the exes ohms now depend we know that we
lose a lot of material they probably
stick to the plastic and we are very
careful to try to have as pure isolate
as possible so you can probably look
into smaller volumes than that so there
are some studies out there suggesting
that you may be able to identify
biomarkers using only maybe 10 or 100
microliters of plasma excel in these
circles but but that remains to be
validated i would i would say dr. chad
great thanks again not a lot thanks for
answering the questions and giving her a
really great talk unfortunately we are
out of time I want to thank the audience
but they're interesting questions and
participation in today's event I'd also
like to thank our sponsor beckman
coulter of course record lot all for
making today's educational webcast
postel today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through becca
culture com you will receive an email
from ladder is alerting you when this
webcast will be about available for
input we invite you before that
announcement to your college who made
this today's live events thanks again
goodbye